ايه ده المشاهدين نبدا من ايران حيث
انتشرت تسريبات تظهر قلق مسؤولين ايرانيين
من هزيمه النظام بالحرب الاعلاميه جراء
قمع قوات الامن للاحتجاجات طبعا هذه
التسريبات والتسريب الصوتي همم سجل تفاصيل
اجتماع نائب قائد البسيج قاسم قريشي مع
مسؤولي وسائل الاعلام طبعا الحكوميه خلال
هذا الاجتماع طلب احد قاده البسيج طالب
الاعلام الرسمي للنظام بضروره الاعلان عن
انتهاء الاحتجاجات ليرد عليه شخص اخر ساخر
بان الاحتجاجات لا زالت مستمره المسؤولون
ايضا تطرقوا خلال هذا الاجتماع الى ان
الاحتجاجات وصلت لاثنتين 62 جامعه وكليه
اضرب احد عشر منها عن الدراسه حديث
الحاضرين طلع ايضا مواقف المرشد الايراني
حيث قال في تسريبات ان خمن ايه اشتكى خلال
لقاء مع احد المسؤولين من صمت اعضاء مجلس
تشخيص مصلحه النظام وعدم انتقادهم للمحت
بالتسريبات هناك اشاره ايضا الى اثنتي
عشره هجمه استهدفت مقر البسيج وايضا مكاتب
ممثلين مرشد ومكتب النائب عن مدينه سيسوار
في البرلمان الايراني هذه التسريبات كشفت
ايضا عن خطه البسيج للقيام باجراءات ضد
امام جمعه اهل السنه في زهدان ملاوي عبد
الحميد طبعا لتدمير مكانته بين الشعب هذه
التسريبات نقلت عن احد مسؤوليه البسيج
قوله في بدايه هذا الاجتماع انه سيتم
توزيعه 10,000 تذكره على موالين للنظام
للمشاركه في مونديال قطر وان هؤلاء
المشجعين يتم اسكانهم في جزيره تايش
ويتمون نقلهم الى قطر لمشاهده المباريات
قبل ان يعود مره اخرى تسريبات نقلت قوله
احد الاشخاص في الاجتماع ان هناك خمسه
الاف كاميرا في الملعب تسجل كل تحركات
معارضي النظام الايراني طبعا هذا بالنسبه
للتسريبات فيما يتعلق بالتصريحات الرسميه
فقد اعترف الجنرال الايراني امير علي
زاديه قائد القوات الجويه في الحرس الثوري
اعترف بمقتل اكثر من 300 شخص في التظاهرات
والاحتجاجات المستمره في مختلف انحاء
البلاد منذ شهرين طبعا هذه الحصيله
الرسميه تقل وبكثير عن الحصيله التي
اعلنتها منظمه نشطاء حقوق الانسان في
ايران المنظمه تقول ان اربعه
451 محتجا و60 من القوات الامن قتلوا منذ
بدء الاضطرابات كما اعتقل اكثر من 18,000
شخص